en bonne seconde que les gens arrivent
Hugues je te charge de débusquer les
boots russes
comme à ton habitude
je disais
tout site un peu un peu porno en Syrie
là boum
allez on est parti
messieurs dames bienvenue on est sur
envergure planetdraft saison 2 épisode 2
on va être encore sur la Watch list on
va encore parler de NC et et pour ça on
va les présenter quand même même si vous
les connaissez déjà ce sont des habitués
à noter que d'ailleurs nos French man de
la dernière fois ont été très bons big
up à Thomas et à Mathias donc les gars
la barre est autre autant vous le dire
ça pousse derrière on va commencer par
celui qui se trémousse
que vous retrouvez aussi sur twitch très
régulièrement le vendredi soir
uguella savait eu comment tu vas salut à
tous salut bah écoute ça va comme ma
connexion tient désolé pour vendredi
dernier parce que j'étais paraît-il dans
le fin fond de la Corrèze sans ADSL
alors que je suis en fibre Île-de-France
Ethernet mais bon écoute je réservais
tout pour ce soir j'ai conservé mon
reste de voix pour vous
ça ça fait plaisir Julien est là et
Julien il a en plus avec une bonne
connexion et ça ça fait aussi très
plaisir salut Julien
ça va très bien bonjour les gars et
enfin Steve et parmi nous qui va nous
parler de plein de prospects
intéressants comment ça va
la forme et toi
impeccable toujours prêt pour parler un
petit peu de basket comme tous les mois
on va faire vous avez l'habitude vous
connaissez donc c'est Wesley donc on va
là c'est un peu des prêts j'ai envie de
dire scouting report de gars qu'on a pas
forcément vu énormément mais dont on
attend beaucoup pour les fraîchement et
pour ceux qui le sont plus les
évolutions qu'on attend pour espérer les
voir le soir de la draft
messieurs on va commencer avec qui
Julien je crois que c'est à toi je t'en
prie dis-nous où tu nous emmènes dans
quel fac fais-nous rêver et nous le GPS
s'il te plaît
ce soir magnifique et on commence par
une des équipes phare tu peux le dire tu
peux tout mimer c'est thousand
California USA et où on va retrouver
très white je vais parler très White qui
est un freshman
alors tu veux que je présente un petit
peu la fac ou je vais direct
un peu mais pas forcément non plus
amateurs
d'une fois plus tourner vers le foot en
fait traditionnellement et mais depuis
ils ont sorti quand même des gros
joueurs moi je rappelle parce qu'on en
parle
Harold meiner qui était baby Jordan
des gros noms quoi et plus récemment au
Kangoo bien sûr
et Evan meublé donc pas n'importe qui
quand même donc des gros joueurs qui
sortent plutôt régulièrement la ces
dernières années après au niveau du jeu
[Musique]
c'est très discutable
depuis aussi de le temps du regard moi
l'impact actuel c'est pas très très joli
c'est vrai pourtant le coach ça fait 10
ans qu'il est là ça fait 10 ans 4
apparitions en marche Madness quand même
plus ou moins glorieuse mais voilà
quatre apparitions en 5 ans je crois
donc voilà et cette année ils
accueillent deux de freshman un petit
peu en vue donc à très White et je vais
pas me rappeler tout le monde c'est
kisani comment il s'appelle
le pivot là numéro 5 qui jouait avec
[Musique]
on sait pas trop quand est-ce qu'il va
revenir
et donc très white je commence sur très
white c'est parti
sur l'impact
au fur et à mesure tu nous feras nous
faire rêver avec la factuel
donc très white freshman 2m3
95 kg donc c'est un c'est déjà au niveau
physique c'est déjà un gars qui est bien
formé qui est assez balèze même en High
School il se faisait remarquer
les premiers matchs avec USA c'est
pareil quoi il paraît pas Freel dans le
jeu c'est quand même un gars qui tient
la route au niveau physique
donc qui sort de prolifique près qui a
une eyeschool assez coté qui a vu pas
mal de gros joueurs sortir
du programme notamment d'ailleurs
bonhomme dont on parlera un peu plus
tard aussi
alors de rôle très différents High
School moi de ce que j'ai vu il est il
porte beaucoup la balle il crée pas mal
le jeu
il shootent un peu aussi quand il veut
et en même temps il avait un rôle de
gros défenseur aussi parce que par
exemple
le dernier tournoi il défend notamment
contre Jordan Wolf et
il fait une bonne première mi-temps en
défense je trouve et puis la défendu
juste avant
alors je crois que c'est Sunrise Academy
un truc comme ça l'école
il a complètement éteint tout le match
vraiment très très impressionnant en
défense en High School alors moi ce que
je voulais voir c'est qu'est-ce qui
pouvait qu'est-ce qui pouvait apporter
côté NCA après c'est premier match après
des matchs que j'avais vu en old school
alors
[Musique]
pour finir avec le physique avant de
parler de son jeu à
jouer si c'est un
c'est pas un joueur très rapide je
trouve pas hyper rapide c'est pas un
joueur qui va très très haut non plus
mais c'est quand même
il est puissant et c'est quand même un
beau joueur quoi c'est pas il est pas
lent je veux pas dire qu'il est lent je
veux pas dire que c'est pas haut mais
c'est pas il y a rien d'élite dans
après
pour parler de son jeu de des quelques
matchs que j'ai vu des bouts de match
qui fait c'est voilà il est dans un rôle
de friendy sur les postes dédiés
toujours bien tourné vers la défense et
les matchs que j'ai vu les bouts de
matchs parce que j'ai pas vu de match
entier en fait pour l'instant de lui
assez dur à trouver du S6 pour l'instant
très très super en défense que ce soit
en un contrat ou en aide
intelligent toujours toujours à fond sur
les sur les ballons sur les lignes de
passe
très investi de ce côté là en défense
et puis avec son corps
ça lui permet de défendre des postes de
des postes 3 de finir parfois se battre
dans la raquette sur des
[Musique]
sur des plus gros quoi des postes 4 donc
très très intéressant assez polyvalent
en défense
on attaque moi j'ai moins vu par contre
quand je l'ai vu c'était assez propre
alors bon les je sais pas s'il faut trop
parler des pourcentages pour l'instant
de tout ce qu'il a fait c'est pas assez
significatif
on en parlera plus tard quand vous
reviendrez il a tiré très peu des
pourcentages sont un peu dégueu je crois
ils sont un peu dégueu je crois ouais
c'est un peu dégueu autour des 30 25%,
je crois mais
quand il quand il veut Pula puis il a
des très beaux poules je trouve il est
très propre sur le foot vraiment il a un
shoot
au niveau des appuis de l'équilibre de
sortie quand il veut shooter en sortie
de course de fées en poulet puis le fait
et il est aussi très très propre en 4ème
chose donc c'est vrai
et je pense que ça joue aussi peut-être
sur son efficacité c'est que tu sens que
c'est un joueur qui est pas comment
c'est spots de shoot qu'il avait High
School et il a pas été mêmes habitudes
ni mécanique ni de jeu donc ça peut
aussi jouer sur le début un peu
compliqué parce que comme tu le dis
passe un rôle où il porte beaucoup le
ballon ou c'est lui qui mène la
transition lycéenne et le fait très bien
un jeu où il est vraiment plus porté Rav
hall et tu sens que pour l'instant il
est pas il est pas en rythme avec cette
équipe de USA
c'est qu'il y a pas vraiment de créateur
en fait il y a deux joueurs qui font
office 2 donc il pourrait il fait des
efforts pour être et ne rigole pas ce
que vous guérisent des efforts pour
jouer pour ne pas shooter ouais si tu
veux et puis il y a Drew Peterson qui
qui
porte beaucoup le ballon qui fait des
bonnes passes mais qui pas vraiment un
créateur élite qui a notre agent
après moi ce que je trouve intéressant
dans cette équipe c'est qu'il y a trois
il joue avec disons deux autres deux
autres deux trois dont un Dyson
[Musique]
et il arrive bien à jouer avec eux quoi
bonne de ce que j'ai vu j'arrive bien à
jouer tous les deux ensemble donc voilà
moi je vais rester attentif sur ce gars
qui est il est pas annoncé très haut
dans les moques je crois pour le moment
mais je pense qu'il faut garder un oeil
sur ce sur ce genre de joueur est lié
polyvalent en attaque capable de 4e
shoot et gros défenseur très agréable
moi c'est un peu Sam ma question par
rapport à lui justement c'est ce côté
polyvalent ce qui est très bien pour
tous les coachs et qui est pas forcément
très bien pour un avenir en NBA on sait
que c'est quand même une ligue de
spécialiste est-ce que justement c'est
pas un gros frein sans être un red flag
mais quand même un frein assez notoire
pour le voir drafté en jouant au
prochain
moi je dirais qu'avec un avec des
grosses qualités en défense
à mon avis un shoot qui va les
pourcentages au chaud vont monter et
le foot existe
tu penses vraiment que à terme ça peut
être un suend quoi c'est vraiment ça
en plus il a une certaine
il peut jouer il peut défendre sur
plusieurs postes donc ça fait beaucoup
de qualité et puis c'est un gars qui a
porté la balle en High School même si
j'ai pas trop parlé de son dribble parce
que
il est pas extraordinaire mais c'est un
gars qui Cédric il s'est posé le ballon
à terre il pourra il peut driver ça veut
dire qu'il pourra attaquer les closas
donc c'est il a pas mal de qualité pour
devenir à mon avis un bon soigne 10 sur
les postés
il a une main gauche pas ouf il a pas
une main une grosse main gauche mais ce
sera pas normalement initiateur de jeu
niveau nbajor de pick and roll par
contre il a une capacité à changer de
main vraiment changer de direction
changer de vitesse
changer la longueur de son dribble et il
prend plutôt bien le contact moi j'aime
vraiment bien ce joueur dans des
effectivement claasote tu l'attaques
transition tu prends le rebond tu lances
et il a pas peur en plus donc pour moi
il a toutes les armes pour être un vrai
cas au niveau supérieur sachant qu'en
plus quand on parle du tir c'est pas
juste un mec qui est dans un corner et
qui tire à trois points c'est un gars
qui peut tirer dans un corner je peux
sortir des écrans on le voyait très bien
s'orienter surtout quand ça arrivait sur
sa main droite sortir de l'écran se
réaccès et tirer et qui peut aussi avec
un petit steback qui maîtrisait au
niveau inférieur créer un décalage créer
un écart donc 21 tir je pose un dribble
je recrée un écart et je tire derrière
donc c'est un frein peut-être allwrence
c'était pas spécialiste quelque part
mais comme je le dis tu défends
athlétiquement une grosse détente sèche
tu as un bout de jeu de la transit tu
vois bien le jeu et tu peux tirer dans
plusieurs situations il y a il y a tout
pour pour séduire
NES
qui peuvent adorer quoi ils peuvent en
avoir 45 mais c'est pour des gars qui
peuvent vite apprécier dès que l'Arabia
un peu aussi
[Musique]
de 2 secondes et tout ça ok
Julien on va revenir à toi après
on va où dites-moi les gars qui se lance
c'est parti on va où dis-nous tout on va
Caroline du Nord et insistate donc avec
un freshman une
plus fraîchement qui est soufflé
des gens avec lui que c'est absolument
donc un combo combo Goa d'un mètre 92
très fin pour 80 kg quelque chose comme
ça de mettre d'envergure donc un joueur
qui grosse grosse qualité
qui a un tir de vraiment assez
impressionnant ça savent vraiment ça
garde d'entrée pour la NBA l'an passé il
était à 37% sur 8 tentatives par match à
3 points donc c'est un gros client il
est capable en plus de tirer sur
plusieurs types de tirs il excelle sur
catch and shout il est capable de sortir
de tirer en sortie de dribble il est
donc il est très efficace par exemple
pour passer pour tirer quand les mecs
passent sous les écrans il aussi aller
sur du step back du vrai step back du
sideback avant arrière et puis il a
surtout une distance il est capable de
tirer à 8 mètres sans problème on prend
tous les tirs il a refuse aucun tir
c'est vraiment un très fort shooter donc
ça va vraiment là dessus je pense qu'il
va être draft après esthétiquement il
est quand même intéressant c'est un gars
qui va quand même assez vite qui change
de direction qui bouge bien qui va assez
haut capable de claquer quand même des
dunks dans le trafic et ses capacités
quand même de se lâcher un peu mais il
manque de puissance manque de puissance
il explose parfois au contact et en
début de saison dernière il y avait
beaucoup de mal justement à poser la
balle au sol aller vers le cercle parce
que physiquement il se faisait trop
impacter mais il a progressé au cours de
la saison et ça ça va être un des enjeux
sur sur cette deuxième année pour voir
si je trouve que c'est ça qui est super
intéressant avec les
retenues ce qui reviennent c'est de
savoir justement où est-ce qu'on les
attend pour qu'il franchissent déjà ce
ce top là parce que moi déjà honnêtement
moi je pensais qu'il allait rester à la
draft et je le voyais drafté déjà ta
Cavern Smith vous avez cette impression
là en tout cas mais qu'est-ce qu'il fait
pourquoi il revient et qu'est-ce qui
doit travailler justement pour se
garantir en fait pour toi une place au
premier tour parce que c'est ça l'idée
je suppose ouais bah le effectivement la
capacité elle est au cercle sur sur la
saison dernière il est à 18 au
freestyright c'est vraiment très faible
mais vraiment en tout cas moi qui
regardait les matchs sur la saison il a
vraiment évolué là-dessus l'agressivité
mais même juste se reposer la balle au
sol et être capable de jouer à
l'avancement début de saison c'était
compliqué faisable au sol il se faisait
impacter tu l'aies il arrivait pas à
jouer et puis au cours de saison il a
commencé à réussir à accéder au cercle
et je pense que c'est un des aspects sur
lesquels il va être regardé parce que si
c'est juste tiré après c'est forcément
beaucoup plus facile à défendre et si il
est capable de TK un peu plus que ça
tout de suite il va être beaucoup plus
intéressant surtout que par sa taille il
peut pas il peut pas il peut pas jouer à
l'aile donc il sera obligé un peu de
défendre sur des joueurs extérieurs et
de porter un minimum le ballon enfin ça
va être compliqué de complètement le
mettre dans un coin dans le sens où il
fait un 92 donc en termes de composition
d'équipe c'est un peu galère de line-up
c'est un peu compliqué
après il est pareil sur la création pour
l'instant il est pas capable de créer
pour les autres câble du cri pour
lui-même sur du tir voilà je disais que
la séparation pour prendre du voilà du
tir en sortie de ripsa il sait faire il
faut se faire très bien même par contre
très pour les autres si c'est pas encore
faire c'est pas c'est pas un bon passeur
pour l'instant et là pareil sur le début
de saison il a pour l'instant même si on
est très faible comme tu disais
il a énormément progressé déjà au niveau
des stades sur les pages il fait
beaucoup plus de passes donc avoir ces
équipes plus importantes avoir sur l'un
des saisons mais ça aussi je pense que
play meeting c'est un aspect sur lequel
il peut être attendu dans le sens où il
sera obligé de jouer sur les postes
arrière en NBA et qui sera un minimum
capable de passer de créer
ça décharge insistate il y a pas
d'intérieur de pic manybet c'est blessé
genre au bout de cinq minutes l'année
dernière ils ont perdu leur pivot ils
ont pas recruter de pivot et Mani bête
séparés et
ils défendent pas ça c'est une équipe
qui aucun mec ne fait un effroi défensif
moi des runny des fonds de départ donc
c'est difficile de juger là-dessus et je
pense que le coach voilà c'est le genre
de programme où il te dit prends le
ballon et Marc et
tu te débrouilles donc ça va être
compliqué de juger les progrès de taxe
Miss collectivement parce qu'il y aura
pas de collectif d'une équipe de N6
state qui va être dans les bas-fonds de
la SSI encore cette année je pense
ouais ou sinon faudrait des stats genre
comme dans certains championnats
exotiques ou quand ils te font une belle
passe ce spectaculaire et te mettre une
place décisive ou un truc comme ça pour
avoir une idée un petit peu si la
progressé ou pas
mais ouais c'est effectivement là encore
on rappelle l'importance du contexte
pour la pour tous ces joueurs
à ne pas minimiser surtout
autre chose à dire Steve sur notre ami
darkavión qui est vraiment vraiment
c'est un peu le cliché du get buggé quoi
ouais ouais très sur le scoring oui ils
défend pas effectivement comme toute
l'équipe ils vont en transition il
pousse bien là-bas il est à l'aise pour
finir et à la passe en transition
parfois la passe on voit faire des
choses intéressantes qui lâchent bien la
balle en rythme
sur le Humble le Haendel est pas mal le
handle est pas mal pas exceptionnel mais
c'est pas mal sur transition est hyper
intéressant sur le drift notamment sur
le poche des règles je sais pas si vous
voyez pas je croise pardon Dream comme
ça qui fait très très très bien pour
accélérer sinon
défense alors pour te rassurer un
draftid il a dit ça toute l'année parce
que c'est une équipe que j'ai subi
malgré moi
insistait été il a dit toujours les gars
vous devez défendre et ils ont jamais
défendu quoi donc oui oui il le dit mais
c'est le genre de coach où il y a rien
quoi
juste pour finir sur la sur cette saison
il va être beaucoup plus ciblé aussi en
défense là déjà le match que j'ai vu
c'est de saison j'en ai vu qu'un de
cette saison il était carrément su il y
avait une boîte sur lui quoi il était
vraiment mal donc pareil voir comment il
va trouver des solutions comment il va
réagir à ça ça t'intéressant et aussi
sur le peu que j'ai vu en termes de
leadership il est beaucoup plus leader
beaucoup plus vocal ça a l'air d'être
vraiment son équipe et il a l'air de
jouer le jeu à fond donc ça aussi c'est
intéressant de voir un peu comme évaluer
sur cette plaie-là
beaucoup c'est l'attitude l'attitude
est-ce que justement il est capable
d'emmener ses gars avec lui
bon pas visiblement sera pas en défense
mais aussi au moins on attaque il peut
le faire déjà ce sera déjà pas mal
Hugues on va passer à toi si tu dois si
tu vois des questions pertinentes
n'hésite pas à répondre
on est là pour ça aussi et puis sinon
dis-nous où est-ce que tu nous emmènes
alors il y a beaucoup de draft alors je
connais pas tous les joueurs qui la cité
notamment Arseno je l'ai très peu vu
pour l'instant c'est nager pas regardé
l'équipe et il nous dit enfin quelque
chose me dit que j'ai pu se regarder
n-systed pour sibron que pour Smith ou
clairement et j'étais horrifié de voir
que le coachenait les ballons attaque
Smith plutôt qu'à son meilleur joueur
l'année dernière mais bon c'est un autre
débat
pour être dans les clichés je vais vous
emmener à baylord vu que c'est mon c'est
ma maison et qu'en plus
il y a il y a une condition interdiction
de dire le nom d'un certain pivot on le
connaît c'est bon on le connaît tous
on veut dire que j'ai pas honte de
parler de Jonathan
tiens-moi tu vois je ne parlerai pas de
Jonathan c'est moi TC H a mwa tu vois je
le promets vraiment il y aura pas une
seule parenthèse mais voilà après le
joueur est blessé toute l'année
peut-être donc
il s'est en tout cas il est prétendu
pour tout de suite n'empêche que Balor
est encore une top équipe mais lors un
recruté qui ont été déjà ce qu'il y a un
top 10 de sa cuvée peut-être top 5 pour
certains excusez-moi
pour le profil physique on a un joueur
1m93 85 kg assez développé puissant qui
a joué imdj Academy un gros programme
qui était un
mec qui va pas très vite un mec qui
monte pas très haut mais un mec qui
domine et physiquement un mec qui impose
sa variation de vitesse parce qu'il a
une très bonne variation de vitesse dans
son terrible et un joueur qui peut
marquer de partout n'avait un gars
capable effectivement de finir au panier
avec contact capable de prendre du mi
distance flotteur main droite tire en
quatre chaînes shoot à 3 points dans les
corners sorti d'écran tir un step back
alors un step back by très explosif plus
proche du set step comme le disait Steve
dans le genre de joueurs mais un tirant
pour la prend confiance on se posait des
questions pour ce joueur sur la capacité
à faire jouer les autres mais surtout
défensivement parce qu'il défendait pas
dans une équipe de belor très complexe
très compétitive qui est pas là pour
pour développer des jeunes on du Ken
dans le bois le dernier qui a galéré à
l'or alors que Jérémy Soran qui avait
une expérience professionnelle a été
performant et
notre ami qui ont été Georges il arrive
et il défend déjà très fort il a compris
le système de jeu il provoque des
passages en force il est bien placé il
va pas jouer la ligne interception il en
aura dans la rotation et offensivement
il joue à côté de deux formeser
Adam Flagler qui sont des 3e 4e année il
leur laisse le ballon et il sait prendre
les responsabilités là des coups de
chaud énorme donc on a vraiment un
joueur moi j'étais impressionné non pas
par les qualités techniques que je
connaissais mais par sa capacité à
s'impliquer dans un jeu déjà assez léché
assez poussé dans une équipe qui se
connaît bien à s'intégrer là dedans et à
gagner rapidement donc ça montre que le
joueur
au-delà du génie qui est coach de roue à
baylord que le joueur a un vrai cube
basket et un vrai professionnel en tout
cas une vraie compréhension du basket et
ça c'est un bon facteur pour le niveau
supérieur
à qui te fait penser un peu dans le
style
c'est dur parce que
il a un peu le physique un peu un peu
fat tu vois un peu
bouli limite un peu surtout lisser là il
s'est un peu affiné enfin en tout cas
c'est musclé ça ressemble un peu à du tu
vois dans le dans le texte du Fred van
de vie de ce genre de petit tanqué mais
un Fred van Lite qui met des gros écarts
au tir un frais de vente vite qui
jouerait comme tu donnes ordi l'année
dernière en attaque tu vois qui était
ça c'est ça donc voilà c'est c'est un
combo on va voir ce qui sait faire
création ballonnement et malheureusement
ça va être le point compliqué à évaluer
parce qu'il joue avec deux arrières que
c'est pas un pivot de pick and roll
flowtumba donc ça va être dur à évaluer
ce contexte là
en tout cas on a un combo qui peut tirer
qui va être puissant nous qui va finir
au panier qui peut défendre qui peut
s'intégrer et qui a un Star profile qui
un vrai potentiel malgré des limitations
physiques évidentes
moi je l'avais vu un petit peu je sais
plus contre quel match c'est un match où
il prend cinq fautes là assez rapidement
à la fin du match il sort c'était un peu
serré et je l'ai trouvé assez comme
disent les Américains émotions donc
assez démonstratif on va dire est-ce que
c'est quelque chose que tu as ressenti
dans le jeu ou pas du tout donc
il peut prendre 5 heures très vite et
les mettre et après il tire du logo
c'est un joueur qui quand à coéquipier
mer Grotten qui bye va se lever quand il
y a une faute il va relever il va taper
etc va provoquer le public donc il y a
ce côté qui manquait un peu à bel-
l'heure un peu nazi donc parce qu'on a
on est dans une fac très porté sur la
religion le coach sort des bouquins ça
fait un peu secs mais genre la joie de
vivre ou la culture du bonheur tu vois
il fait des déjeuners avec sa femme ses
enfants ses neveux et tous les jours ils
sont invités et ils meurent ensemble
dans un truc évangélique tu vois ça fait
Far Cry 4 c'est très mais
c'est exactement ça avec au fond tu vois
un peu de Mariah Carey pour Noël et
cetera mais il arrive à développer tes
joueurs avec des gros égaux quand même
qui ont été genre Jérémy Soran qui est
un peu taré aussi donc ça marche bien
franchement c'est le profil est
intéressant
Julien on va retourner vers toi parce
qu'on est passionné en fait de pas que
twelve pas du tout
et c'est bien normal le meilleur
commentateur de l'histoire de
alors j'ai pas dit lui aussi c'est une
fac de l'autre de elle est et la
deuxième grosse fac de la première selon
comment
bien sûr
qui a fait rêver tellement de monde et
notamment moi et je voulais parler je
vais faire un petit peu de retour en
arrière donc t'as pas envie notamment
moi
avec Jérôme
très très loin ok
Adam Bona moi je voudrais parler
d'adapona d'abord
donc je suis deuxième fac je vous
présente une grosse fac
voilà
qu'on voit souvent en marche ma nièce
voilà qui sont aussi quand même quelques
joueurs un peu tous les ans donc c'est
sympa quand même et
voilà moi j'ai commencé à donc à bosser
avec toi envergure au moment où la ou la
le programme pris par que je croyez et
je pense que j'ai eu de la chance parce
que avant c'était la c'était la catast
et le marasme et depuis quatre ans
prenez une fin de travail très fort sur
sur le programme il a il a remis des
joueurs à l'endroit il a
il a fait jouer son équipe donc il a
emmené à la marche Mendes plusieurs fois
éliminer notamment dans un très joli
match quand même on se rappelle tous
avec Suns qui contre Gonzaga qui
crucifie à la dernière seconde du ciel
et des moments de bonheur et donc voilà
un programme assez sympa un coach un
coach carré quoi
et puis dans cette équipe il y a plein
de il y a pas mal de joueurs qu'on que
moi personnellement j'aime bien voir et
Adam Bona se rajoute
pas mal de ces joueurs
je sais que tu aimes bien raquette c'est
pour ça
[Musique]
alors c'est un intérieur qui est né au
Nigeria qui a grandi au Nigeria jusqu'à
l'âge de 13 ans je crois qui a suivi sa
mère et puis qui a été recruté en même
temps au même moment qui partait en
Turquie il a été recruté sur
sur une petite vidéo sur l'entraîneur
avait balancé comme ça il a commencé de
le basket très tard
et d'une interview assez touchante de
lui là juste avant de
de me connecter ou il raconte un peu son
enfant comment il est recruté c'est
c'est une histoire et je pense que c'est
le genre de joueur justement avec ces
histoires un petit peu complexes qui
arrivent
[Musique]
à quel âge il a je crois qu'il a 19 ans
il y a peut-être avoir 20 ans tu vois 19
20 ans mais qui a déjà une longue
histoire derrière lui et je crois que
c'est un petit peu comme Charles Basset
qui est maintenant au Spurs qui passait
par où est-ce qu’entokiste un peu même
genre de d'histoire j'avais cru lire ça
pareil je shabbaté qui arrive qui est
pris qui loge chez sonkos il vient un
peu ses parents de cœur et puis après il
évolue il est repéré et puis voilà il
fait son bout de chemin
une histoire très dure avec un de ses
parents qui meurent très jeune voilà
donc c'est des joueurs qui ont qui ont
une vie avant
voilà et donc il apprend le basket en
Turquie et après il rejoint attend j'ai
pas me tromper près de police après la
même fac la même High School que celle
de très loin et dont on parlait tout à
l'heure alors il a joué derrière Nate
little le fameux qui est le
pivot d'origan et puis alors
tu l'as fait et voilà allez on y va de
mettre 7 de mètres 9 j'ai pas trouvé une
tu vois des mensurations très claires
sans de 100 200 6 kg et
je crois 2 mètres reste d'envergure tu
vois
de maîtresse non non c'est bidon c'est
de mettre 20 non je suis pas sûr ça me
paraît un peu court pour se donner
j'ai mis à jour le site aujourd'hui
c'est demain
voilà alors
j'ai fait une petite fiche moi j'adore
ce joueur j'adore ce joueur je l'ai vu
jouer la dernière fois là avant cette
année c'était eu 20 c'est ça c'était
magnifique
c'est un gaillard c'est vraiment un
gaillard un haut du corps très développé
en même temps très vif très explosif
très puissant
verticalité assez impressionnante quand
même
et puis il s'est se déplacer avec son
gros corps et c'est une boule d'énergie
je pense que déjà au niveau physique ça
ça cadre le gaz c'est une boule
d'énergie mais très généreux quoi pas
moi j'irai pas dans la violence dans la
générosité il aime donner tout sur un
terrain quoi vraiment et je voulais en
parler un peu après mais c'est un gars
qui dégage une envie de jouer au basket
de qui est super
bien avec un programme universitaire je
trouve les dégâts aiment bien se cacher
comme ça au niveau du jeu
il a commencé tard voilà donc
c'est
il se comment dire s'il arrive jusqu'à
un rime Runner ce sera un Remer avec je
crois que Thomas on parlait dans quand
il a fait des articles là sur les pivots
c'est typique ça c'est un gars qui en
gros défenseur de grosse protection de
cercle
et
puis en attaque c'est un finisseur quoi
un finisseur qu'on a envie de voir jouer
du pick and roll j'attends sa relation
avec take Campbell justement
ils vont se régaler tous les deux
donc en défense
alors qu'est-ce que j'avais noté moi
déjà ça son corps et ça détend tu vas
mettre de voilà protéger le cercle de
mettre des bons contre les biens blocs
bien haut bien bien sympa sur la France
là cet été contre la France ou le 22
vous en rappelez de les deux bâches
[Musique]
qu'est-ce que j'avais noté moi je pense
qu'il a il a les qualités
comme il est comme il est vif il est
très vif dans les petits espaces et il
est costaud moi je le vois bien devenir
un bon défenseur en EDGE ou en drop
voilà parce qu'il sait il s'est anticipé
alors il va falloir qu'ils se comment
dire qu'il se canalise aussi par pour
pouvoir être efficace là dedans et puis
par contre je l'ai pas trop vu défendre
sur des petits joueurs encore
nous de la hauteur des hanches
ce que j'avais noté en haut au niveau
lycéen c'est que il se faisait beaucoup
attaquer j'entende de gravité poste bas
il se faisait beaucoup en français il
avait pas encore fait de renforcement
musculaire mais ça m'aide très jeune un
mec à développer le basket à cet ardent
donc il a pas encore les réflexes de se
mettre l'avant-bras en opposition dans
le dos etc donc il se fait beaucoup
prendre des petits coups et reculer mais
ça va apprendre par la suite son
problème il s'en mêlent un peu les pieds
aussi même en défense parfois s'il est
pas il est pas très très stable quoi et
puis côté attaque c'est voilà vous avez
noté c'est un finisseur
mais ça voilà j'avais noté ça pour toi
Hugues je trouvais qu'il faisait des
beaux écrans c'est un beau poseur
d'écran
il pose des beaux écrans avant de rouler
et ça ça fait quand même très plaisir de
voir de temps en temps ça de pas avoir
des gars qui s'échappent
et voilà puis on a envie de voir finir
plus souvent de voir monter au Cercle
c'est moi je devais prendre quand même
quelques je crois qu'il fait ça en une
un deux il a pris quelques fautes bon
ben c'est pas c'est pas trop son truc
pour l'instant mais
voilà pour l'instant je me rappelle pas
les pourcentages dans les compétitions
internationales ou lancer France c'était
correct ou attends
[Musique]
sur ce genre de profil on aime quand
même bien quand on fait un pivot qui a
au moins 60 70 % quoi il est sur alors
il prend 48 ancêtres je te dis pas de
bêtises en 48 ans c'est franc il en met
33 il a 69% quoi
c'est quand même plutôt assez il a une
vraie routine quoi il a une vraie
routine au lancer franc et puis il fait
il finit quoi
est-ce qu'on est je te couper excuse-moi
est-ce qu'on est susceptible de le voir
faire un petit peu autre chose à l'UCLA
ou pas parce que maintenant on aime bien
utiliser les pivots pour être un petit
peu aussi à la place pour être pas que
être des des lampes target sur sur des
Aléo pour que tu penses que ça va être
compliqué de voir ça à ucelet
alors
Thomas il en parle dans son dans son
article moi j'ai vu quelques passes
aussi
j'ai noté ça au U22 après
peut-être peut-être avoir quoi après il
a pas beaucoup joué là pour l'instant et
du ciel et il a fait il a pas fait tous
les matchs parce qu'il est je crois
qu'il était blessé les deux premiers et
il y a quelques minutes voilà mais il
est
au niveau de l'attitude il est super
industriel il se fondent dans dans le
collectif il adore ça il adore jouer
pour la pour son équipe et dans une
équipe il y a pas vraiment de grand
parce qu'il y a deux joueurs qui font
office 2 donc Mack Étienne Macky tienne
quand même avoir une ou deux fois dans
sa vie quand même incroyable et il y a
une opportunité de jouer plus parce que
quand même pas c'est quand même pas
super non plus et avec ses qualités de
avec ses qualités de finisseur et avec
ses qualités de protection certes il va
je pense qu'il va se montrer dans son
équipe donc il a la chance d'être de
pouvoir s'exposer toute l'année et je
pense de faire le tournoi final donc ça
va être pas mal pour lui
est-ce que tu penses que il sera
suffisamment prêt pour juin 2023 ou que
potentiellement il peut rester un petit
peu de du côté de Los Angeles
parce que il y a quand même un côté très
brut chez à Duba pour le moment
ouais mais ça dépend le projet d'une
franchise quoi si il trouve que
ils ont des choses à développer assez
tôt c'est lui pourquoi pas ça peut être
le pivot rime Runner du second tour cher
Alan qu'on embrasse évidemment
toute façon je pense que même après deux
ans il aura pas plus haut que que ça
quoi je pense et gros revendeur défensif
aussi vous avez noté je voulais dire
parce que c'est vraiment une de ces
grosses qualités
ça marche
dans le bon timing donc on va pas
s'arrêter là Steve je te redonne la main
dis-nous où on va
on va Duke
donc Nouvelair après le départ de coach
qui est là depuis 41 ans je crois c'est
ça donc ils sont assistants qui prend le
relais d'une nouvelle équipe qui a eu
quatre draftés je crois vérifier mais
bref renouvellement d'équipe complet par
une feuille blanche et la recrue la plus
côté parmi les fresh même c'est Dary qui
est donc c'est un arrière lié
il fait il fait 1m98 pas le poids mais
il est plutôt plutôt costaud athlétique
très jeune joueur il est né en août 2004
voilà et il s'est fait remarquer en High
School à mon Verdez il a gagné le titre
il a été élu meilleur joueur lycéen de
la saison
il a un potentiel pour moi de tuer c'est
un gars qui est capable de staurer aussi
potentiellement à trois niveaux capable
d'aller au Cercle un bon toucher
costaud donc qui gère plutôt bien le
contact il est très à l'aise sur le tir
en sortie de dribble il aime bien tirer
à mi distance ou à trois points en
sortie de dribble parfois un peu trop il
a un bon foot work des bons fondamentaux
très à l'aise sur les japstets enfin de
départ pour créer de la séparation pour
qu'il améliore sa sélection de tir pour
être vraiment plus efficace
ensuite en défense il est hyper
intéressant c'est un gars qui m'aime au
lycée défendait il a le physique pour
pouvoir défendre sur plusieurs postes de
3 peut-être 4 en tout cas en basketball
sur un billet on verra mais même en
défense au football il est intéressant
il est toujours concentré partiçu pour
rebond il y a le physique aussi pour se
mêler un petit peu justement la bataille
du rebond et pour l'instant il a juste
joué un match qui s'y fracturé le pied
droit c'était au mois de mai je crois
donc il a repris l'entraînement il y a
deux semaines et l'entraînement
collectif il y a une semaine il a joué
juste 16 minutes dans les matchs du Duke
on va falloir un petit peu attendre pour
le voir en NCIS pour prendre le rythme
tranquillement mais c'est un joueur qui
a un profil hyper intéressant qui est
hyper fluide et très beau à voir jouer
moi j'aime beaucoup je trouve assez
smooth c'est vraiment assez élégant et
donc là il est projeté entre 3 et 10
grosso modo donc il sera hormis
catastrophe il sera le réplique
justement ces cinq tu peux utiliser le
mot tu as dit tu joues assez smooth ce
qui est vrai et en même temps il a aussi
pourtant on a l'impression que c'est un
mec qui peut devenir très très musclé et
tu vraiment une espèce de de bulldozer
physique cette alliage là qui à mon avis
doit faire un petit peu rêver enfin en
tout cas c'était les vœux en ice school
c'était on a l'impression que c'était un
homme parmi parmi les enfants vraiment
il y avait ce côté vraiment bête
physique qui qui ressortait en premier
lieu et qui était très très
impressionnant
Hugues tu l'as vu un petit peu d'Harry
whited
je l'ai vu un peu niveau lycéen j'ai pas
j'ai pas vu le match de Joe j'ai vu
qu'il avait pris 11 tirs 16 minutes il
m'a régalé mais j'ai pas vu le match de
duo
j'ai vu un mec effectivement qui tire
beaucoup
moi la question que je me posais pour ce
joueur c'est aller au panier je trouvais
qu'il avait pas trop envie d'aller au
cercle il prenait beaucoup de pull-up et
c'était un reproche qu'on faisait
beaucoup de mecs style Tate qui est
ensuite mon travail derrière et sont
devenus des grosses stars et est-ce
qu'il peut faire jouer une équipe parce
que
Duke va jouer avec deux intérieurs Duke
a pas Jérémy rothsch qui expérimenté et
qui parle à mettre à jouer tarif pour
que tu aurais plus un swing
va pouvoir jouer des ballons Ball en
main
en gros est-ce qu'il va pouvoir
reprendre le rôle de Paulo bancaire ou
quoi ouais voilà dans un profil moins
physique mais
pour être un top 5 de draft dans une
cuvée aussi chargée est-ce que tu peux
devenir une pièce offensive principale
de ton équipe dans un jeune projet et ça
c'est vase je regardais principalement
cette année
ouais sur le playmaking tu avais vu ou
lu des choses aussi par rapport à ça non
j'ai pas assez vu là pour avoir un avis
tranché là-dessus et puis ce que j'ai lu
c'est que justement il y avait il y
avait des avis il y a ces divergents sur
ses qualités de passe sur l'Ender donc
ça va être effectivement comme disait vu
que ça a été un enjeu voir s'il est
capable un peu d'initier effectivement
avec Duke mais non moi j'ai pas de
d'avis tranché là dessus
est-ce que dans le comportement bon pas
à Duke parce qu'il a fait que un bout de
match mais dans High School il avait ce
côté
cet étoffe de star un petit peu parce
que si les draftés ont top 5 de cette
année ce sera voilà c'est ça qu'on
espère avoir est-ce qu'il a cette étoffe
là cette assurance là ce côté un peu
très sûr de lui que peut avoir l'année
dernière belle nature par exemple voilà
ce côté voilà je vais y arriver je vais
tout défoncer ou comment ça s'exprime
chez lui
quand même assez dominé le gecko l'année
dernière il a il a une niveau de la
confiance il a il prend des tirs parfois
en rythme à 8 9 mètres dès que les gars
ne laissent pas les bras donc c'est je
pense que là-dessus c'est pas il y a
cette capacité dans la tête en tout cas
avoir envie de prendre une équipe sur
son dos et on est capable c'est autre
chose mais en tout cas je pense que
mentalité de l'approche qu'il a de son
jeu la confiance en version jeu oui il a
et à l'attitude d'un leader
autre chose à dire Hugo
ou Austin
au niveau de comment il est ouais un
petit peu parlé Hugues sur sur le
contexte de Duke qui a un peu
particulier parce que c'est un nouveau
coach et puis aussi d'une équipe qui a
été quand même largement remanie donc ça
ça peut être aussi à la double tranchant
quand même non
comme d'hab tu as beaucoup beaucoup de
jeunes
ce que j'aime bien c'est que dans les
jeunes tu étais jeune qui sont tu as des
basketteurs Philippe
oski je vois dans le chat est un vrai
intérieures
du spacing avec la vie c'est plus un
projet albatros et ce jour-là est assez
sûr quoi Mark Mitchell Mark Mitchell
je suis pas fan de Mark Mitchell mais
c'est un mec que ton vent mission
défensive Proctor fait pas beaucoup
d'erreurs il fait pas c'est pas un
énorme potentiel donc tu as beaucoup de
jeunes
mais tu vois que tu peux laisser de la
marge d'erreur et étant sortir parce que
ça peut jouer clairement au basket donc
moi j'aime bien avoir cette équipe quel
rôle il prend offensivement parce qu'il
manque pour moi Duke là actuellement
dans les tous premiers matchs cette
superstar offensive ça joue bien au
basket mais ça joue pas comme une équipe
qui a 5 mecs du top 25 quoi donc
est-ce que water peut prendre tes
responsabilités là est-ce qu'il peut
être le mec qui fait basculer à money
time parce qu'on a vu du jour on galère
dans des fins de maths etc moi j'ai très
hâte de voir ça
va être forcément à suivre Duke cette
année encore une fois parce que là
encore une fois on parle d'un vrai
prospect d'un mec qui est souvent
annoncé tu étais gentil de Steve en
disant 3 et 10 quand j'ai plus vu entre
3 et 6 que 3 et 10 donc il y a beaucoup
beaucoup d'attentes autour de Darry
quited donc voir qu'on va évidemment
suivre et suivre
on va vers où dis-nous on va aller vers
vers de la haine on va aller vers faire
du Prozac on va aller vers dilan
Mitchell à Texas
parce que parler des gros potentiels qui
peuvent réussir c'est cool et parler des
joueurs qui sont très annoncés très fort
il y a peu de qualité c'est moins bien
ils étaient bien dans la liste des
Mitchell non pas du tout
je change de joueurs
pardon messieurs c'était pourquoi parce
que j'ai regardé Texas aujourd'hui et
j'ai eu envie de gerber donc on va pas
parler de Mitchell on va parler de on va
aller dans l'amour
on va aller dans le dans le sophomore
dans le basketteur expérimenté on va
aller Jordan rockin's à Yukon lui dit
lui
déjà l'année dernière qui ont parlé sur
twitch ouais j'ai abusé toujours d'amour
je crois novembre dernier j'ai dit lui
c'est l'autre hippique monsieur dame et
bon il revient il est Sophos morts
malgré la grosse cuvée pourquoi l'an
dernier je joue à Yukon freshman dans
une équipe très expérimentée du code il
est avec
Martin qui ouais Hugo excusez-moi j'ai
fait du Texas il avait time très
expérimenté qui va jouer cette année je
crois
Atlanta enfin bref un joueur qui a été
tu vois player il y a air jacquole qui
est parti en Europe donc il y a vraiment
beaucoup de joueurs et ils se retrouvent
en sortie de banc avec assez petit que
pour un coach dan early dont on l'avait
vu avec book night
fait jouer les vieux même si tu es le
meilleur joueur il fait jouer les vieux
au début des années tu peux t'amuser
mais à la fin de l'année c'est 40
minutes pour les titulaires donc il a
été un peu mis de côté
cette saison il y a Tristan Newton qui
arrive avec lui au sein de biscarrolina
les païens ma voile part en couille le
meneur expérimenté et le joueur fait un
premier match commotion cérébrale je me
dis merde [ __ ] c'est le premier match
et il se blesse il a réussi en 8 minutes
à tirer 10 fois il me régale et ce que
j'aime chez ce joueur donc là il revient
de blessure et tout de suite il prend
beaucoup de tirs ce que j'aime c'est que
c'est un gars qui n'a pas peur
on est sur un profil 1m98 on est sur un
gars qui peut partir ma droite partir ma
gauche qui peut vraiment créer un écart
qui peut faire un système faire un step
back qui peut poulet qui a une vraie
détente qui reste longtemps en l'air qui
absorbe le contact finalement à droite
finalement gauche et qui est
défensivement est hyper agressif donc au
minimum à mes yeux tu as un profil de
Sween dit un mec qui tourne à 36% à 3
points l'an dernier
avec des beaucoup de tirs en fin de
possession et qui prend toujours des
fausses le meilleur porteur de
baladverses donc au minimum tu es un
joueur pour moi swindy assez safe et en
plus de ça tu as une envie chez le mec
peut-être un gros scorer
voilà il y a tous les ingrédients qui me
qui me font kiffer d'un athlète du tires
tu défends tu as une volonté tu as du
temps de jeu tu as un beau programme tu
as un vrai pivot avec un Sanogo tu as un
vrai meneur expérimenté beaucoup de
coach il y a tout romain pour que je ne
fasse une grosse saison et j'ai très
très hâte de le suivre en tout cas voilà
dans la comparaison on peut s'enflammer
mais il y a ce côté
alors je vais pas trop bon
on va dire
bonjour
Non mais il y a ce côté
ce que toi il meurfit est en train de
faire avec nurling cette saison donc qui
prend plus de trucs ballants etc il y a
un peu de ça quoi qui est un très bon
défenseur grosse corones gros tireur et
qui a montré des qualitat athlétiques
pour finir au panier qui se développe au
naso de joueurs là et pour moi ça peut
être un des premiers swing dit appeler
l'actué et justement toi qui l'a suivi
l'année dernière qu'est-ce que tu
attends comme progrès de notoire là où
tu
vas dire ah oui là il a franchi un cap
la sélection de tir l'an dernier est un
joueur qui est un peu frustré qui est
très souvent montre sur le côté du
terrain dans le corner je suis là je
suis dispo et qui tape des mains qui
s'énervent un peu en mode GT ouvert
donne-moi la balle de pas la balle
donne-moi la balle tu vois et cette
année
il est un des trois leaders de l'équipe
avec Sanogo à l'intérieur Newton donc
voilà tu vas avoir tes tickets de tirs
tu vas avoir tes tu vas voir tes ballons
calme-toi prends des bonnes décisions
essaie de de mieux faire jouer les
autres aussi et camion propreté ce sera
ce sera beaucoup mieux il faut qu'il
soit plus propre et ce qu'il a une
grande variété de dire moi j'ai eu
l'impression quand je voulais dire que
j'ai vu j'ai l'impression d'avoir vu un
peu tout le temps les mêmes tirs
assez peu
je conseille le mastoder contre obur et
contre Michigan State qui sont les deux
gros matchs le battle for atlantiste
commenté par Bill Walton donc ça c'est
cool à regarder
tu as un mec effectivement dans les
corners qui vont un mec qui met des
sextape notamment même mi distance tu
vois je m'arrête et je déclenche et dans
les sorties d'écran ce que book là il
faisait très très bien aussi je sors de
ce flopy que Yukon fait très très bien
avec deux poseurs d'écran je me ré et je
vais déclencher rapidement il a un tiers
qui part très très vite donc moi j'ai
ces trois tirs là et j'ai la capacité à
frotter poser la balle aller au
sainte-maritime je trouve qu'il a une
palette un peu complète la question
c'est de savoir est-ce que tu sais
quelle tiers prono quel moment est-ce
que tu sais lire une défense ça va
falloir qu'il progresse
ok
Julien repart dans la pack twelve avec
je vois et volupté
exactement mais on va quitter Los
Angeles on va monter un peu au nord
dans la fac de Reborn on va
ah ça Rebug
ça Rebug un peu est-ce qu'on t'aurait
entend là ou pas non c'est bon là c'est
bon vas-y ok
elle va c'est pas nous comme
quitté Los Angeles
[Musique]
qu'on adore envergure
dans l'orthographe
il a une
réelle
elle est pas mal celle-là
on est assez fan
alors j'ai plus son âge là je crois
qu'il est jeune il a il a 19 ans je
crois 18 et 19 ans qui vient d'origan
j'ai oublié de le noter
le plus moche et alors ça c'est pas bien
mais franchement c'est pas bien après
c'est très très c'est ma connexion est
pourrie quand ta connexion est pourrie
tu te tapes chez eux c'est horrible
parce que là
voilà il est pas moche mais c'est dur à
suivre quand même les matchs
moi j'adore la forêt et je sais que
Romain il déteste ça moi j'adore la
forêt du parquet romain le capitalisme
il adore que les building tout ce qui
est vert
mais par contre c'est vrai quand ta
connexion est pourrie suivre on rigole
c'est vraiment très très compliqué
on sent de Hackman c'est comme ça qui
s'appelle leur coach
alors c'est très un programme très
bizarre ou parfois les recrute plein de
plein de seniors tu vois tout d'un coup
qui débarquent au début de la saison
donc c'est très compliqué pour mettre en
place tout ça
tu as l'impression que l'année elle est
foutue dès qu'elle a commencé et puis
petit à petit c'est une équipe qui est
capable de
remonter la pente de finir champion de
la pactuel ce qui est quand même un
explorat les gars c'est pas donné à tout
le monde et puis de faire un petit tour
ou de en marche Mendes ça c'est aussi
pas mal et voilà Oregon c'est un peu ça
on ne sait jamais trop ce qui va se
passer au début de l'année mais il faut
quand même garder un oeil sur eux
dis-le
quand même sorti quelques gars
non plus
histoire de Oreo magnifique et donc que
les joueurs qui se retrouvent au milieu
de deux autres intérieurs alors
maintenant on se rend pas trop compte
parce qu'il a pas trop joué il a été
souvent blessé et il commence cette
année pas mal du tout au niveau du
scoring il va être titulaire je pense
qu'on a un long moment et puis donc
netbuttle dont on a parlé tout à l'heure
qui a un grand pivot on reparle je vais
en reparler tout à l'heure parce que
leur relation avec where est vraiment
bien pour l'instant et donc lui que les
lois de mettre 13 95 kg seulement voilà
envergure je n'ai pas trouvé j'arrive
pas à trouver je sais pas du tout où
elle est mais elle doit être pas mal
alors moi le premier match que j'ai vu
de lui c'était un high school donc
et le gars contre tout le monde mais
tout le monde
et le gars contre tout le monde et en
plus il met des trois points donc je me
suis dit bon ben voilà c'est c'est
pour ça parce que c'est pas c'est pas ça
en fait c'est pour tu vois c'était pour
faire un effet d'annonce mais bon il est
encore un petit peu vert à tous les
niveaux
mais il a sa qualité principale moi je
trouve que c'est la protection de cercle
il a vraiment il a vraiment ça il a des
il est très vif pour se déplacer dans la
raquette même sortir en closer qu'il
arrive à le faire aussi pas mal
et puis il a un sens de la protection du
cercle qui est vraiment intéressant
après
alors moi ce que j'avais vu en High
School c'est qu'il était capable de
jouer justement avec ça de jouer avec
les
adversaires pour je vais le contrer j'ai
pas de contrer et puis arriver à les
gêner
je vais voir s'il y arrive au niveau
supérieur parce que ça veut dire plus
compliqué bien sûr
parce qu'il jouait voilà avec son
envergure avec son avec sa taille son
envergure et ses qualités ses qualités
de Jump il était vraiment au-dessus High
School High School North Little Rock
Arkansas c'est ça et jouer avec Nix Miss
junior qui a pas débuté sa saison là
parce que j'ai compris
quelques jolies passes pour des
finitions assez hautes donc voilà donc
voilà gros gros défenseur
[Musique]
vraiment un foot qui part de pas
forcément très haut d'ailleurs pour un
grand non plus donc c'est aussi de voir
sur la transposition tu sais
[Musique]
ça fait plus la question
je suis allé voir le alors
au Mexico c'est ça cet été les USA il a
joué avec les USA
et c'était vraiment très très pénible il
y avait pas trop dans le jeu il mettait
50 points tout le monde et j'ai la
gueule tout le temps enfin c'était
terrible
là là c'est là c'est le début de l'année
les matchs que j'ai vu les c'est
beaucoup mieux quoi c'est beaucoup mieux
dans l'attitude il est c'est assez
positif
et voilà et puis il y a cette relation
dont je voulais parler avec Beetle qui
est super intéressantes ils sont des
basses entre eux comme les deux peuvent
flouter
à l'extérieur les deux sont capables de
d'aller scorer dedans il y a un jeu de
passe entre les deux qui est super
intéressant ils savent se servir ils
n'ont pas peur de se passer le ballon
extérieur c'est vraiment chouette
qu'est-ce que tu penses du contexte de
d'ouragan alors Hugues à David bien
tranché mais tu nous parles de trois
intérieurs ça fait pas un peu beaucoup
pour une équipe NCIS là pour l'instant
il a il a eu du temps de jeu je pense
qu'il va en gratter d'autres après
malheureusement et je souhaite pas du
tout parce que
il est souvent saute tout le temps c'est
terrible quoi alors que c'était quand
même un sacrifice
moi je pense qu'il va avoir sa chance et
de toute façon c'est un c'est un gars
qui veulent exploser quoi dans les dans
les interviews d'avancer ils savent que
c'est du one and down et ils vont ils
vont le montrer ils vont ils vont le
faire jouer et
c'est un gros talent quoi de la pactole
c'est le prospect le plus pour l'instant
qui est le plus haut dans les moques et
à juste titre parce que
le comment dire le plafond est très haut
pour ce joueur le plafond est montré tu
l'as vu à quel niveau là pour l'instant
toi dans les mois
dans les 10 c'est un truc comme ça 10-15
au niveau du contexte je sais pas qui a
cette année origan au niveau du
playmaking parce qu'on sait souvent
d'ailleurs sont assez dépendants du
premier King c'est un peu le problème
est toujours là
donc ça apporte quand même ça prend du
jeu ça
écarte le jeu et puis après il est
entouré de voilà il est entouré de ses
morts
voilà qui sont des métiers mais c'est
assez étonnant en fait cette fête de
dragon il y a des il y a des plans de
il y a plein de joueurs qui craignent
qui sont doués dans la digue et qui sort
de rebond quand même
mouillé un truc comme ça qui a traîné à
Dallas et je sais pas où c'est sans
dorigos ouais c'est vrai
je l'ai vu jouer je sais plus et oui les
il est au moins Angelique il est pas au
Thunder je sais plus enfin bref
Julien merci
on repasse à toi Steve tu nous emmène où
un peu surprise l'année dernière ici qui
était l'équipe le plus cool à regarder
avec beaucoup de joueurs expérimentés
des mecs de 22 23 ans comme Charlie
Moore et qui me remet Gusti et dans
cette équipe là il y avait un gars un
peu plus jeune et le joueur qui est plus
intéressant pour la drape qui s'appelle
Isaïa Bong donc on va parler là c'est
officiellement c'est un forcière junior
parce que ça veut dire en gros sa
quatrième année
c'est un combo 1m90 80 kg c'est un
joueur qui est plus âgé que les joueurs
que j'ai présenté jusque là parce que
lui il a 22 ans il est janvier 2001
le vieux que Théo
sa qualité principal en quoi je
basketball c'est le 1 contre 1 joueur de
un contrat donc il est très bon pour
pour créer son propre tir pour créer de
la séparation il a un premier pas rapide
il a un bon Haendel un cross assez
efficace qui permet d'accéder au cercle
en défense c'est un joueur en dépit de
son gabarit assez près qui fait le taf
il est très actif au niveau des mains on
pense bien son manque de physique par
une belle activité mais évidemment au
niveau au dessus pour que défendre des
posters au mieux au mieux
les enjeux cette saison pour lui c'est
bah c'est de le voir dominer ça doit
être un des meilleurs joueurs ici au
niveau du scoring notamment c'est aussi
la question de la création pour les
autres
et puis bah il a un profil qui est
difficilement exposable en NBA dans le
sens où il a pas forcément le talent
pour être une première option pour être
un ministère principal mais en même
temps il a pas du tout le profil en tout
cas il a pas joué du tout comme un rôle
player depuis à la fac donc
très curieux de voir comment il va
pouvoir essayer de trouver sa place par
NBA en tout cas ça passera pas par la
draft je pense que s'il vend une pièce à
la petite porte c'est des petits
contrats c'est la jellyx et c'est comme
ça ça sera pas sur sur la drape mais
c'est un jour que j'aime bien donc je
voulais en parler un petit peu voilà
exactement c'est un joueur vraiment
assez c'est le genre de joueurs qu'on
aime bien voir parce que c'est amusant à
voir quoi c'est un mec c'est
complètement fou fou par moment ça
réfléchit pas trop c'est très instinctif
ça va vite et où il y a vraiment le côté
explosif qui a rajouté à ça après c'est
sur le niveau du shoot c'est un peu
striqué
c'est vraiment fouteur de série alors
faut espérer que les séries soient pas
oui mais pas dedans soit pas trop longue
parce que sinon le match peut être long
pour Miami mais sinon ça reste un joueur
qui est sympa avoir joué enfin moi
personnellement j'ai pris du plaisir à
le voir évoluer
qu'ils ont recrutés aussi
nickel il vient de tissu qui est un
poste tout pack ninja pack voilà
merci Père Fouras
la même voix on est bon oh là là on est
à niveau ce soir incroyable
[Musique]
de pertinent ou pas c'est vrai que le
profil NBA c'était un peu haut et c'est
un gars qui a profit la finir en
peut-être sans être c'est pas mélissant
de dire ça mais
à Taïwan ou un jeu comme ça où il pourra
prendre beaucoup de tirs et
un peu ce côté encore très très fou où
on peut le voir en Europe
imaginez qu'il soit cadré pourquoi pas
ouais pourquoi pas donner mais après en
Europe ça joue pas toujours parce que
nous on a l'image en Europe de toujours
des équipes qui sont bien structurées et
des équipes en Turquie ou ça joue
n'importe comment enfin entre guillemets
ça joue faut que ils puissent trouver sa
place en Europe je pense oui oui quand
même c'est vrai après est-ce que c'est
un vrai meneur ou pas moi j'aime pas
l’impression qu'il avait forcément tout
le temps la balle dans les mains dans
cette puissance
et là c'est pareil il y a de aussi
en deuxième arrière quand voilà sur un
main ou enfin voilà il se démarque et là
il en attrapé jouer mais c'est vrai que
c'est pas lui qui organise et qui est
une histoire principale c'est pour ça
que c'est un profil un peu particulier
évident à intégrer dans une équipe mais
tu fais tu fais bien d'en parler quand
même parce que si les gens voient qu'il
y a un match de Miami et qui tombe
dessus ils peuvent aller cliquer parce
que c'est c'est sympa à voir quoi
vraiment c'est sympa à voir même si
après ils seront une bise sans doute pas
mais c'est pas grave il y a quand même
le côté amusant qu'il faut prendre en
compte un Claude Pleaser comme on dit
c'est encore à toi
on va travailler j'économise je vais
faire cours crédit Dick
que je vois Kenza de mettre ses rois de
mettre 0,3 qui est peut-être peut-être
messieurs le meilleur tireur de ce que
fait c'est un ça tombe bien c'est
exactement mon type dis donc est-ce que
c'est le meilleur footer
en 4G en mouvement oui il y a ce côté
quel cover il y a ce côté Mac darmotte
en moi athlétique près du panier il y a
ce côté
voilà c'est un joueur qui court tout le
temps
qui met des grosses filoches qui a pas
peur c'est pas un très gros athlète près
du panier il y a un manque de finition
il peut donc
des cas pivot en face il passe le ballon
et défensivement il joue beaucoup la
ligne de passe parce qu'il a pas les
qualités pour rester en face du joueur
donc on joue beaucoup l'interception
joue beaucoup la style joueur très
intelligent qui va avoir un contrat NBA
faut épais sur le corps mais on sait ce
qu'il va faire il y a pas grand chose à
dire je me dis que il va être sur le
terrain mettre des trois points courir
et il aura deux trois quatre contrats
comme ça
et est-ce que
quand ça s'en rappelle les champions
titres
est-ce que ils peuvent se permettre de
développer d'autres facettes de son jeu
à ton avis
ou est-ce que même c'est pertinent en
vue de la draft
tellement son profil semble déjà acté en
fait ce qui est intéressant à voir c'est
son pas si game parce que Kenza ça joue
très bien ensemble ça vise à back to bac
parce que janano Wilson est très fort on
en parle dans le chat
l'emmenant de jeu des ronaris devient
razzone roundo like il est il a vraiment
leur pivot dont j'ai oublié le nom là
UD du freshman très athlétique très
puissant donc voilà on a kenzas dominant
mccullard gros tank en transfert
dominant donc on va voir comment
crédit Dick défaut comment gagner Dick
peut venir faire chier des postes 3-4 et
voilà mais en tout cas il va il va
tourner à plus de 40% à 3 points et il
va mettre des filoches toute l'année
c'est vrai que c'est ce jour de jour on
a l'impression que ils ont déjà trouvé
leur rôle en fait donc c'est vrai qu'on
les attend pas vraiment sur autre chose
et que si on veut autre chose entre
guillemets ce sera que du bonus et puis
ce sera tant mieux pour lui
donc voilà oui j'ai on avait aussi un
message sur sur Twitter qui n'a pas
encore fermé que justement de parler de
Wilson ou qu'on fera pas là mais
évidemment super joueur de façon c'est
un joueur on pensait qu'il pouvait
peut-être se présenter l'année dernière
finalement il a pas fait il sera
peut-être pour cette année et c'est
aussi un gars qu'on pourrait retrouver
un bon bon vétéran du second tour qui
pourrait très très bien partir
en meilleur passeur
je pense qu'on fait un twitch dessus
dans trois semaines en gros une fois
on va vite venir dessus parce qu'on
connaît le joueur et il a fait le combat
et la question le petit meneur que j'ai
comparé à un c'est bien des rois Naris
qui franchement il y a un très bon
passeur il fait des grosses fins des
grandes mains donc voilà à regarder
et ben super granélique a d'ailleurs je
sais pas vous connaissez
complètement vous connaissez la marque
de beurre de cacahuète d'acacine
non en fait c'était un enfant tout blanc
et que des bonnes joues qui faisait
néerlandais et ben je trouve qu'il a la
même tête c'est gradinique mais jeune tu
vois c'est ça fait penser à ça quand je
l'ai vu j'ai fait c'est le mec de la Pub
enfin bref voilà
on va rester sérieux pour ça on va
compter sur Julien
un homme d'expérience
c'est pas très sympa mais c'est vrai
c'est parti on retourne à retourner du
ciel et pour parler Dammarie Bailey
c'est
franchement je vois ce que tu as écrit
c'est ça c'est mon joueur mystère c'est
un pic c'est un prospect
5 étoiles
ouais c'est un peu le groupe prospect de
cette année de
cinquième chez lesbienne un truc comme
ça enfin c'est vraiment l'annonce de
folie quoi
mais bon voilà il a alors pourquoi
pourquoi il est il est annoncé si haut
donc c'est un combo de entre 1 m 94 1m96
je pense
84 kilos assez léger mais très
athlétique c'est un joueur athlétique
vraiment
c'est un joueur qui qui est fort sur la
quantité lancée en vitesse et puis faut
avoir en fait quand il est lancé
il sort de 4 années je crois c'est ça
à côté de brownie James
donc il était plutôt ses bonnet qui
avait la balle en main très souvent lui
il était créateur secondaire on peut
dire je pense comme ça en tout cas il
était pas porteur de balle primaire
grosse année au scoring
et donc il arrive à Los Angeles avec un
gros pedigre
alors ce qu'il y a c'est que bon alors
dans ces caractéristiques c'est c'est un
joueur qui est qui a peur de pas grand
chose en fait je trouve ici il attaque
le panier il shoute il a jamais peur de
prendre ses responsabilités ça c'est sûr
il a un rondelle un maniement de balle
qui est qui est intéressant
il est vraiment capable de faire pas mal
de trucs de drivés de
des forces sur soi under
mais par contre il prend pas toujours
les bonnes décisions avec il est capable
de s'empaler dans les défenses il est
capable de foncer tout droit sur les
sur les pivots adverses au niveau du
Drag il y a des choses à revoir enfin je
trouve ou alors j'ai pas vu des bons
matchs pour l'instant et
par contre hyper inventif si
quand il pour finir au panier pour
trouver la pour trouver l'ouverture pour
placer sa main pour finir au panier des
super inventifs c'est vraiment très joli
à part quand ils s'empalent c'est ça
dans les dans les pivots ou même avant
avant de commencer son délai
après au niveau du foot je trouve que
c'est alors juste pour finir souvent de
lit il part souvent d'un gosse aussi ça
pose beaucoup beaucoup sur la main
gauche
mais après il a quand même plein
d'autres choses sur soi-même il est
gaucher aussi
il a l'hésitation il a le il a les fins
de visuelle il a beaucoup de choses il a
beaucoup montré beaucoup de choses dans
la School mais pour l'instant c'est
beaucoup moins de gauche au niveau du
shoot c'est assez problématique c'est
vraiment résumé dans ton dans ton titre
c'est est-ce qu'il va arriver à shooter
ce qui va arriver à stabiliser son shoot
quoi ce qu'il est capable de faire des
séries en 4e foot assez sympa il a
le problème c'est qu'il adore le poulet
puis il arrive à se créer des poulettes
il aimait pas quoi et là le début
d'année le début d'année c'est un petit
peu c'est problématique
la bonne nouvelle c'est que
son
coachère chronique là il lui fait
confiance et on le voit dans les matchs
la façon dont ils discute ensemble donc
il le fait sortir rentrer il y a
beaucoup de dialogues je pense il parle
beaucoup et il a la balle en main il
hésite pas à lui faire créer du jeu il
joue avec donc un meneur expérimenté
Campbell et puis avec deux autres deux
autres liés Jaden Clark qui fait un
début d'année les gars extraordinaire il
faut aller le voir on défonce et quand
il commence à s'y en plus seront c'est
vraiment chouette alors c'est un
guerrier magnifique mais c'est pas un
créateur et puis il y a single tonne qui
a deux trois shooter je suis très
particulier mais qu'il est tout en ce
moment mais qui est pas non plus un
créateur donc
il va avoir il va avoir les ballons pour
créer pour et je pense que il va s'en
servir parce que c'est plutôt un bon
passeur après il va falloir un moment
qui rentre ses sous si effectivement
confirmé ce qu'on a attendu quoi et des
fois si il manque qu'est-ce qui vaut
pour l'instant à Marie Bélier et ben
écoute il défendait par intermittence
d'après ce que je comprends la School
c'est un peu ça
par contre un spécialiste et
mais des matchs que j'ai vu les quatre
matchs qu'il a fait 400 j'ai pas vu
bailar j'ai pas vu bailary mais il est
c'est ballot mais
vraiment bien il est dans le temps de
toute façon il est dans une équipe
là-bas le choix s'il défend pas il est
dans une idée encadré par des gars qui
défendent qui jouent qui ont envie
d'aller loin dans la marge ma nièce donc
il va il va défendre il sait le faire il
a les qualités parce qu'il a des
qualités physiques qui sont pas mal il
peut défendre des un des deux il est un
peu léger pour l'instant pour défendre
des trois mais pourquoi pas le voir là
dessus
et puis après il va falloir qu'ils vont
dire il a envie de défendre
il va falloir qu'il soit plus attentif
comme beaucoup de jeunes en football
parce qu'il adore regarder la bague il a
tout le temps les yeux sur le ballon
quand il défend mais ça c'est peut-être
une comment dire un défaut à très
classique quoi voilà après c'est un
joueur qui est suivi il est suivi depuis
il a fait les
U16 américains il est il a fait tous les
McDonald's je sais pas quoi il leur
somme classique tout ça c'est un gars
qui dit donc
[Musique]
le monsieur est référencé
est-ce que moi c'est un peu du mal sur
le profil parce que est-ce que ça peut
exister encore un jour qui se fait
drafté si il y a s'il est pas élites en
défense et que il a juste un shoot à mi
distance est-ce que ça profite RAV4
surtout quand on fait un mètre 94
moi je pense que c'est un défenseur très
correct ça peut être un défenseur très
correct vraiment
et
après le problème c'est le shoot en
général quoi
et je vais être capable d'être un combo
quoi moi je me demandais en fait je me
posais la question
tu vois le trouver 3 à 3 joueurs à le
comparer NBA
ce serait dur mais bon il joue quoi le
gaz joue mais je pense qu'il a
et puis après je me disais pourquoi pas
mais Jordy il avait un gros foot quoi
c'est un bon défenseur tu vois ce que je
veux dire défenseur
combo tu vois ça pourrait être
[Musique]
parce que des deux comme ça je sais pas
si vraiment à la base
il faut être un fort combo donc il faut
de la passe de la défense et
c'est pour ça que moi j'ai beaucoup de
mal pour l'instant le projet alors c'est
tout début saison il est fraîche pas et
c'est peut-être pas encore adapté au
truc et tout ça
le feu mais toi que tu en penses quoi du
profil
ultra justement le projeter
au niveau lycéen mais j'en avais assez
peu vu trois quatre matchs
j'aimais bien sa capacité à faire jouer
les autres j'aimais bien sa capacité à
manipuler visuellement la défense à
envoyer des mecs en orbite vous cherchez
des Oléo avec une seule main la capacité
à acquis qui est voilà moi je trouvais
que c'est un un truc de son jeu qu'on
est on mettait pas en avant on met en
avant le joueur individuel et je
trouvais qu'il y avait une capacité à
faire jouer les autres qu'on verra
sûrement
qui est chronophage et qui est très très
bon et avoir et tu vois c'est drôle
parce que moi je trouvais qu'il y avait
un manque de de gestion du contact alors
que souvent c'est ce qui met en avant sa
puissance c'est un explosivité et je
trouvais assez désaxé au contact donc je
me dis est-ce qu'au niveau supérieur tu
vas faire de la transition tu vas
envoyer un orbite et tu développes ton
tiers et tu apprends à mieux gérer ton
corps avec gros athlète il y a une porte
d'entrée peut-être en second tour
peut-être angélique mais il y a un vrai
profil je suis pas amoureux il va pas
être dans mes chouchous je préfère mon
très white dans la dans la pack toile
beaucoup moins côté pour le coup
et voilà il y a un profil à développer
il y a un truc à rajouter sur l'ami
l'ami à Marie Bailey
le premier supporter de lactuelle de
France
exactement 2024
un petit peu
j'en profite pour ceux qui sont encore
avec nous n'hésitez pas à balancer vos
questions il reste deux profil et puis
après on fera un tour des questions
avant de finir une petite FAQ des
familles donc n'hésitez pas à poser vos
questions c'est maintenant
[Musique]
Steve on est reparti avec toi
on va rester en Floride on va voir
on va un peu attendre avant de le voir
malheureusement
donc poste
4 5
la taille j'ai donc c'est un espagnol
déjà
en espagnol qui joue au Real Madrid
franchement et au niveau de la taille
c'est j'ai entre 2 mètres 0.6 et 2
mètres 11 donc pour l'instant je sais
pas pas très pressé mais il est long et
sa principale qualité c'est que il bouge
très très bien pour sa taille
et que il a une dextérité assez
incroyable que super main que ça soit
pour le dribble ça soit pour la passe
soit pour le tir parce qu'un jour qui
est capable de dribbler passer tirer qui
fait près de 2 m 10 donc juste ah ça le
rend hyper intéressant c'est
[Rires]
tous ces choux l'année dernière
la différence c'est que il est quand
même de meilleure main notamment au
niveau du Haendel que je viens de Butler
donc là il savait tiré il se déplaçait
très bien en défense profil athlétique
c'est assez similaire je pouvais dans
l'accord sur le profil athétique sur ce
qui permet de faire en défense avoir un
attaque quand même il a un peu plus il
est moins brut au milieu et plus de
basket plus de fondamentaux et
cet amour ça s'explique parce qu'il joue
meneur jeune j'ai trouvé cette info là
où en fait il était il faisait 1,90 14
ans il jouait plutôt arrière puis il a
pris en deux ans il a pris du coup près
de 20 cm enfin
trouvé sur des postes plutôt intérieurs
au moins il y a mais il a eu le temps de
développer comme ça une dextérité de
d'arrière quoi et il est capable de
faire des passes des axes main droite
main gauche de faire des petites passes
crochets comme ça sur du driving kick de
te faire dribble dans le dos dribble
entre les jambes quand il est sous
pression dribble de recul
c'est assez impressionnant assez
exceptionnel et très bon sur le tir
enquête inshoot
donc dans le corner est capable de
sanctionner avec efficacité en défense
pareil comme il est mobile il est
capable d'aller un peu partout sur le
terrain c'était très bien il est
intéressant sur les seconds rideaux on
est défensive il est
très bon sur les close out il a bien
cherché les gars il a des bons appuis il
replient en transition il va vite en
vitesse de pointe il y a eu des actions
que j'ai vues sur des chaises donne où
quand il court en sprint il va vraiment
vite donc il est intéressant aussi sur
la transition puisque c'est un joueur
qui va vite sur la vitesse Nord-Sud et
peut-être pouvoir switcher notamment un
potentiellement c'est quelque chose qui
peut développer on verra la silicapable
de le faire à ce niveau là mais une
Colombier je pense que c'est un projet
envisageable pour une franchise de dire
on va faire défendre sur du switch
ensuite dans les défauts il est assez
frais donc il manque de puissance donc
pour la protection de cercle c'est un
problème je pense surtout à NBA ce sera
problématique qui sera impacté il aura
du mal à tenir le choc au rebond aussi
se faire bouger et c'est pas un joueur
qu'on a vu dans un contexte ça soit au
Real Madrid en jeûne ça soit avec
l'Espagne parce qu'il a fait les pompes
jeunes avec l'Espagne on l'a jamais vu
sur un rôle de coureur tu as toujours
été un garçon utilisé en rôle player
donc avoir comment il va être utilisé à
faire une assiette mais c'est pas un
garçon qui met 20 points par match et ça
sera pas le cas je pense même en NBA
donc voilà et puis pas pour finir
suspension 16 matchs voilà donc on va
attendre avant de le voir jouer avec
avec les seminos
surtout leur réseau de la suspension qui
affreuse quoi
en fait il a les vrais
l'aller-retour en avion parce qu'il est
en Espagne l'huile les a remboursés mais
c'est une violation du règlement parce
qu'on lui a fait un peu de vin Olympi en
billet d'avion et donc suspension de ça
ce match donc bien joué là NCA
on passe plein après que les mecs ou je
sais pas où qu'on fait des dingrées
comme ça c'est ça
il y a un mot qui revient souvent sur
Baba Miller c'est le côté justement
fluidité certaines élégance cette chose
là qui est quand même quelque chose sec
certains peu long et on sait c'est
difficilement explicable en fait c'est
que lui ça c'est vraiment ça c'est ce
côté l'impression que tout ce qui fait
est très facile mais après c'est aussi
un joueur moi ce que le que j'en ai vu
c'est avoir qui c'est j'ai l'impression
qu'il connaît il connaît ses capacités
donc il fait pas des choses non plus qui
ne maîtrisent pas trop donc on a
l'impression qu'il est tout en contrôle
donc peut-être qu'il peut paraître
encore plus fort que qu'il est en fait
il est qualibaba
mais oui oui c'est en fait il a toujours
été dans les équipes fortes en fait
les équipes c'est les All Star Game des
prospects
il a des gars pour pour prendre des
responsabilités et là il est dans une
équipe il y a quand même il y a Matthew
qui gland qui a déjà noir qui va mener
mais il y a quand même moyen de de
scorer c'est pas il y a pas non plus de
gros gros joueurs
voilà capable de se correr donc ça va
être intéressant de voir s'il va être
capable justement de sortir du schéma
dans lequel il était habitué de jouer et
d'apporter un peu plus parce que c'est
vrai que le potentiel le profil hyper
intrigant et moi je suis hyper intrigué
par ce joueur et bah ça se voit sur les
moques il y a parfois on peut le
retrouver en 15 14 puis parfois je l'ai
trouvé en 40
qui est très très large c'est logique
puis le profil
même jusqu'au bout je pense
des gens qui vont mettre en avant ses
doutes notamment suivi qui est tout
frais etc etc
Baba Miller qu'est-ce que ça vous
inspire d'autre moi j'ai mis le sous
côté parce que j'ai l'impression qu'on
n'entend pas beaucoup parler de lui
quand même évidemment les joues pas donc
ça n'aide pas mais
j'ai pas l'impression qu'il y a une côte
d'amour qui est extrêmement haute enfin
c'est vraiment le un peu un prospect FC
Twitter pour l'instant ou à peine
d'ailleurs
pas de scoring je pense que c'est pas un
garçon même quand on regarde du C4
regarder le match tu vois des en U18
c'est 5 points par match avec l'Espagne
ou le Real donc je pense qu'il y a de ça
je suis assez d'accord on parle pas
beaucoup on entend pas beaucoup alors
que juste le profil athétique
normalement ce type de joueur
c'est intrigue et ça ça voilà ça attire
tout de suite l'oeil alors que là non on
a un gars de quasi de 10 qui fait
dribble entre les jambes qui désaxent
tout capable tir à trois et c'est vrai
qu'on en parle pas énormément et en plus
dans une fac qui qui provoque ça quoi
[Musique]
Isaac Kevin va seul
Léonard Hamilton qui est le coach de
cette équipe il aime ça les les mutants
qui étaient des petits arrière et du
grenier d'un seul coup donc normalement
même si l'équipe de forêts est
dégueulasse depuis 2 ans c'est
une équipe mais mes équipes préférées et
c'est horrible les rotations c'est
horrible mais normalement le projet le
style de joueur c'est quelque chose de
maîtrisé par par forêt d'Astate
ils font all switch tout le temps donc
ils adorent les profils ils défendent
moi j'aime bien comment ils défend déjà
ils sont en avance en très fort ils ont
vraiment une volonté de gagner la balle
très haut sur le terrain et donc ils
adorent les profils dédiés comme ça très
très long qui a pas de switcher de
défendre deux trois quatre c'est
vraiment leur came voilà
Steve merci beaucoup on va finir avec
Hugues avant de prendre vos questions
sur le chat n'hésitez pas je rappelle
pour finir en beauté ou pas d'ailleurs
en brutalité je sais j'ai choisi 8 morts
de Villa Nova qui est
un monstre physique qui a alors oui les
Américains ont eu 18 ont roulait genre
tous les autres pays à d'Amérique Nord
centrale et Sud mais lui la démoli la
concurrence
pour le profil on est sur un 6 6 7 donc
autour des 2 mètres
hypertend qu'il est hyper en avance
capable de enfin slasher qui va arriver
au panier qui va finir d'être demain qui
va finir avec la faute grosse mentalité
et qui va toujours défendre le meilleur
en tant de balades vertes la question
c'est la même que pour beaucoup de
joueurs c'est de tir est-ce que comme
Isa gros ça va pêcher au tir est-ce que
tu as une Bron lui a réussi à passer un
step par son tir et par sa finesse de
jeu il peut faire ça c'est la question
qu'on va se poser dans une équipe de
Villa Nova orpheline de Jay white
nouveau coach très expérimenté avec
beaucoup de joueurs qui vont être postba
mais pour l'instant il est blessé donc
on va attendre qu'il revienne il va pas
jouer avec de vrais intérieurs
normalement c'est dans les semaines de
prochaines semaines on espère parce
qu'ils sont ils ont deux défaites à
l'horizon défaites contre temple qui est
une très grosse équipe avec califat et
donne et ils ont perdu contre Michigan
State qui a un mode d'effectif donc rien
à fOLAN
[Musique]
et on va attendre de voir moi ce que je
vais regarder c'est la gestion des
petits espaces comment est-ce qu'il peut
tirer oui ok on va regarder mais est-ce
qu'il peut naviguer dans un périmètre un
peu bouché est-ce qu'il peut trouver
plus d'anglais ce qui peut rester parce
qu'il peut changer de vitesse est-ce
qu'il peut ralentir et accélérer
vraiment regarder ça
parce que après derrière il faut
toujours espérer l'équipe avec des idées
j'ai pas eu d'équipe qui disent qu'un
élite corner
donc là ça peut le gros donc c'est le
gros le gros c'est peut-être l'un des
trois meilleurs de ce que tu fais
ouais
est-ce que il y a aussi un parcours un
petit peu étonnant enfin sur ce que j'ai
lu sur Camille est mort c'est que c'est
quelqu'un qui a fait sa ça hype entre
guillemets en quelques mois au mois
d'avril l'année dernière en fait entre
mars et avril vous savez il a explosé il
a pop-up d'un coup complet quoi et avant
il était un petit pas sous les radars
mais on parlait de parler beaucoup moins
quoi c'est un joueur les opportunités
black menant darkson avec la coupe afro
qui va très mauvais début de saison
malheureusement chez toi mais voilà il a
pris les devants et après il a bénéficié
de ce genre de compétition jeune ou le
basket est organisé où ça va très vite
en transition et on explose tout ce que
Jedi avait très bien fait avec l'équipe
américaine elle est pour duo avant de
faire une très très grosse saison donc
voilà la clé on le connaît le basketteur
dans une académie de basket qui est
Villa Nova
très hâte de voir
une nouvelle étape voir si sa capacité à
s'adapter cette super intéressante aussi
parce que justement comme tu as dit
c'est quand même un basket d'école
normalement c'est connu pour ça en tout
cas ça l'était peut-être quelque chose
changement de couche ça va changer mais
il y a quand même pas trop de raison non
plus
messieurs on va faire un dernier tour
vous allez me citer quelques joueurs
dont vous auriez aimé parler mais je
vous ai imposé de parler que de quatre
joueurs donc c'est juste pour les
mentions nobles je vous fais ce plaisir
et pour Hugues il y a une contrainte en
plus pas le droit de recycler des
joueurs qui étaient déjà là l'année
dernière
pas de nouveau parce que j'en ai un mon
gars sophomore c'est le meilleur meneur
de l'ancien d'accord
mon petit moneur de jeux
à mettre 88 l'an dernier c'est le
meilleur passeur ennecy en termes de nom
de chiffre le meilleur intercepteur avec
un ratio assistant never exceptionnel
sauf qu'il y avait pas d'attaque il y
avait pas de tir il y avait pas de
finition au panier et cette année à
Texas dans l'équipe menée par Chris bird
avec Marcus kart avec Dylan Mitchell le
prospect avec Timmy Allen laffre Timi
Allen
c'est un pivot d'1m95 quoi qui joue
postba et voilà Hunter mais des tirs
énormes et il a mis 26 points là contre
gants de Saga il les a détruit il met
des gros poulets pas trois points c'est
le plus petit d'une fratrie de 11 donc
en termes de mentalité pour faire sa
place il est là donc regardez alors dès
que ça c'est pas très beau mais regardez
il y a la défense en défense un homme
c'est un des meilleurs NCIS il y a le
leadership il y a le passing game il y a
le développement de ce qu'ils le seul
problème c'est la taille avec 88 mais
on en a vu d'autres qui réussissent à
NBA avec cette telle
etc donc pour moi c'est une très très
grosse cote pour un tome 20
mais on va en parler j'espère un jour
plus attention j'adore ce joueur même si
je sais pas du tout s'il va être raté un
gars j'en sais rien mais ce serait
vraiment ballot et sinon il y a des deux
arrière de Gonzaga donc il faut parler
sadis
et creuser Hitman le bonheur
de défenseurs vraiment pas dégueu ça
c'est vraiment un gros gros défenseur
c'est un athlète il va falloir qu'il
apprenne à attaquer plus proprement on
va dire mais il y a vraiment de
perspectives j'adore ce joueur et le
meneur Hickman franchement je garde un
œil sur lui cette année et puis dans
toujours dans la de Baby donc la
conférence de Gonzaga il y a un certain
Maxwell Lewis qui pourrait s'y met des
choses un petit peu en ordre dans son
jeu être vraiment un beau joueur
bientôt même cette année je pense
il y a eu des beaux échos par rapport à
l'année encore cette année non
la qualité de jeu etc non c'est pas ça
jusqu'au fond des dernières c'était la
galère totale ils ont
mais il y a comment il s'appelle
et
c'est qui Jany Wright de l'intérieur de
l'USA beaucoup faisons parler tout à
l'heure j'avais oublié son nom
voilà et sinon votre timide les gars
après j'arrête non mais c'est fini moi
je voulais juste dire de semis parce que
cette année
encore plus fort que l'année dernière
et enfin la même question pour toi Steve
est-ce qu'il y a d'autres joueurs qui
viennent comme ça qui méritent le coup
d'œil
on a parlé dans le chat j'aime bien ou
qui a un grand capable de tirer de
s'écarter
c'est un joueur très costaud qui a déjà
un corps de joueur NBA qui joue à l'aile
qui était un transfuge de Kentucky j'ai
pas de bêtises qui est arrivé l'année
dernière et que j'aime bien
après je l'ai pas vu mais qui a une
belle cote qui est un 5 étoiles sur un
programme qui d'habitude il tient pas de
5 étoiles donc c'est intéressant à voir
c'est déjà Starling à Notre-Dame voilà
et
oui je pense que là
[Musique]
si le chat n'a plus de questions
messieurs je vais vous libérer et je
vais aussi me libérer parce que demain
je me lève très tôt malheureusement
merci beaucoup Julia Hugues Steve ce fut
un plaisir dans la joie et la bonne
humeur comme à chaque fois
quant à moi pour le planète draft
épisode 3 on va parler de prospects or
États-Unis
donc ce sera courant mois de décembre
comme d'habitude on vous prévient sur
les réseaux sociaux alors Twitter si ça
existe encore Instagram ou sinon autre
on vous verra ou on vous enverra pardon
des pigeons voyageurs si besoin mais au
pire vous retrouverez vous activer la
cloche sur Youtube et comme ça vous êtes
sûr de ne rien rater et d'être présent à
chaque émission on vous embrasse bien
évidemment on vous fait des bisous et à
au mois prochain bye